hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play scp-432 now
this is a newer SCP game that you
probably haven't heard of I barely I
almost missed it as looking over for new
games to play um it's about this SCP
that I've actually read up on in each
pot you know about it's basically
equivalent to the cupboard to Narnia
if Narnia was a barren hellscape of
death and despair actually it's pretty
similar to Narnia so um basically it's
kind of whoa what Hey
whoa that okay that launched a webpage
don't know why what the hell it's all in
Russian okay I'm guessing this game was
made by someone not in America which is
fine because a lot of the games I play
are not made by Americans which is fine
America torment Barry who knows not all
right here we go basically you enter
this kind of cabinet thing whoa hello
whoa yeah oh what's that
ah who are you who the hell are you
whew I like this yeah this is just a
test version now where'd you go did the
football work I don't flip out always
worked okay so from what I've read I
died oh how did I die
oh you barely got in there what the hell
that goal huh what I guess I did walk
right towards those eyeballs
haha turn at me again I'm sorry what are
you looking at yeah that's right [ __ ]
yeah here all right so this flashlight
or whatever I got is not very intense
haha
anyway everyone commented the atmosphere
in the music is really nice I love I
love like the violin or cello lines you
know good peeking around the corner
nothing hooky haha
I don't know what the hell go you need
to stop that okay like I said this might
be the beta version so added hard
monsters but on a hard monster who
doesn't want a hard monster oh goodness
gracious but yeah I would I would
compare this more - more than scp-087 B
or oh eight seven AK you again you
you're always a started huh whoa hey I
see you whoa ah what I don't know I
don't know how to win those stupid
eyeballs are like staring at me in the
face okay so anyway I would compare this
more to SCP Oh eight seven then -
anything else re i'ma check what am I
doing wrong
I can't read anything because it's in
Russian the webpage that leads me to is
in Russian all right it's gotta be
something I'm doing wrong
gotta be I mean it can't be this hard
can it
if I just you'll move forward and keep
moving maybe because I was standing in
one spot if I keep moving maybe I'll be
better 54
no I got me okay this is the monster
test version Joe let me know get me
wrong I want to play the game hang on I
mean let me go I'll be right back let me
let me go configure some stuff in the
background see if I can get this to work
like maybe I can get a different version
of it just get more atmosphere to give
you guys an idea of what the game is
going to be it's not done it's very
early so don't judge it based on this
whole I'll be right back
hello everybody I'm back okay so I got a
new version of the game called the map
test version there was a map test and
then there's a monster test version
because this is early so I want you guys
to see how the map is because I really
like how atmospheric it is so this one
should not have a monster and it should
just be the thing the SCP itself so I
want to I want to give this a chance to
explore because hi hey you said it was
gonna be I'll turn this one hey get out
of here
hi okay all right you stay way the hell
over there I'll go this way now I don't
know if this is randomly generated I
seem to remember coming down this way
before in the last version but I'm not
sure I thought I thought there wasn't a
monster in this version hello
paper-thin walls hmm okay there's a lot
of dead ends here if at that it's like a
freaking maze from what I read of the
SCP it's more of a I like that music but
holy hell seriously this has a lot of
potential to be great it's got you know
it's got an almost perfect atmosphere -
oh hey what oh hi hahaha hey look
leave it leyland is this a be the paper
ha floating up in the wind hotel okay
there we go yeah do you okay so the
monster is actually not implemented here
so hopefully there won't be any more
jump scares but maybe disappoint Oh dead
end but I just want to give this game a
thorough look be
because I'm very very very excited to
see some developers making really
interesting stuff about a lot of the SE
PS and there are a lot of SCPs I mean
this guy could want done this lately
different I mean this guy could
collaborate with the guy that does SCP
containment breach because SCP oh it 7b
was you know it's randomly generated and
this one doesn't seem to be randomly
generated but the atmosphere and the
gameplay is great it's made on the Unity
engine if I'm not mistaken and possibly
maybe he could get some tips and
collaborate that's interesting
I don't know how much I can explore
there does not seem to be a lot here oh
I'm back okay well I guess I gave it a
thorough look man all right so obviously
this game is in very early stage so if
you try for yourself try the monster
test version and see if you can figure
out a way to get farther than I did
because when I was doing that obviously
I only made it a few feet and you know
it does have a lot of potential this
game could be great let me give you
something to look at here this game
could be great you know I really like
the atmosphere if they add like randomly
generated areas and stuff like that
it could be phenomenal so give it a look
yourself show them some support for what
it is so thank you all so much watching
links in the description below and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
whoa Wow what the hell